now to our covid coverage a team of  researchers from texas tech may be  changing the future of coronavirus  testing  with a brand new way to detect it they  say not only is it faster  it's also just as accurate as the  regular pcr  and rapid tests but the best part no  more nose swabs the team of four reach  researchers has come up with the new  covid19 test  instead of nasal swabs all you need is  some spit and you get your results  in seconds all these process takes less  than a minute right whatever the person  provides the saliva and then you put it  in the device  so because it's super fast you could do  as many testing as possible the  coronavirus tests  are becoming an everyday thing  in this world right now instead of  having to wait for our test results  for a day or two how about getting it  you know right after giving your sample  their goal  as you just heard is to mass produce the  test so people can have it in their  homes and use it whenever they want  christian